the European Union is looking for young
talented graduates and experienced
specialists in the field of audit
recruits undertake a variety of external
internal and xposed control audits they
provide assurance to management by
undertaking audits in a broad range of
EU policy areas examining compliance
with laws and regulations and value for
money the experienced specialists will
also lead audits assignments supervising
the audit team auditors will work
primarily in the European Commission in
Brussels and the European Court of
Auditors in Luxembourg both capitals
offer a diverse and vibrant city life to
apply for the Graduate profile you need
a university degree or a professional
qualification in a relevant field to
apply for the specialist profile you
will also need at least six to seven
years relevant professional experience
of which at least three to four years in
the field of audit additionally all
candidates must meet the following
requirements
XOS Equal Opportunities policy ensures
all qualified candidates have a fair
chance for more detailed information
please visit auditors dot EU - careers
dot EU shaping Europe together
[Music]